les minions vous ne vous êtes jamais
demandé d'où ils viennent il vibre sur
cette planète depuis bien plus longtemps
que nous ils sont tous différents et ont
tous le même objectif servir le maître
le plus moche et méchant qui soit
trouver un maître était plutôt gens et
la pignada le garder c'est là que les
choses se gâtaient mais non ce n'était
pas facile pour eux pourtant ils n'ont
jamais abandonné
l'eau au papa gueye natale et bella n'a
pas failli est ce que loeb ou n'a jamais
rêvé de travailler pour le plus grand
super méchant de tous les temps
les nouvelles recrues bien non non non c
est beaucoup plus jeune comprendrait
rien
vous savez qui c'est fait la course à
l'arrière ça c'est la reine elizabeth et
et je veux vraiment vraiment vraiment sa
couronne pour la couronne de la reine
c'est ça il vous faudra passer sur le
corps du gardien de l'hapoël
foulant watch
pas très cool il ya pas de scarlett qui
tiennent surtout ne le prenez pas mal
mais je boude et s est maintenant
torture les gars arrêtez c'est vraiment
pas professionnel
gp l'arrêt